three common openings for white you  should know a common way a game begins  is with the solid move  e4 controlling the center black  typically responds e5  the game frequently continues with  knight f3 and  knight c6 then usually one of three  popular moves  bishop c4 known as the italian game  black often responds bishop c5  you could also play bishop b5 which is  known as the roy lopez opening  a popular response for black is a6  white typically retreats the bishop to  a4 and if attacked again  moves the bishop to b3 which attacks the  weak f7 pawn  instead of bringing out the bishop white  can also play d4  putting pressure on the e pawn and  opening lines for the queen and dark  squared bishop  this is known as the scotch opening